Salut Romain, ça va ?
Non, j'ai la gueule de bois.
J'comprends pas pourquoi.
Ah, ça a peut-être un lien avec les 9 litres d'alcool que tu t'es enfilé hier soir, non ?
Tu crois ?
Ok...
Si comme Romain et moi-même vous aimez boire un verre avec vos amis
le soir venu, vous connaissez forcément ce sympathique état second
qu'on appelle la gueule de bois.
Et comme il faut connaître son ennemi pour mieux le
combattre,
on va se pencher un peu sur la question.
L'expression de gueule de bois
viendrais du fait d'avoir la bouche sèche
comme du bois un lendemain de soirée
trop arrosée.
Mais que c'est loin d'être le seul
désagrément de la situation
et c'est même le plus gentillet, à vrai dire.
D'ailleurs depuis on a trouvé
d'autres termes pour décrire ce syndrome
comme la xylostomiase par
exemple.
Ça claque, hein ?
Hé, mais en vrai, "xylo", en Grec, ça veut juste dire "bois" et "stoma", ça veut dire bouche.
Retenez le quand même, ça pourra vous
servir
Bonjour patron, désolé d'être en retard,
mais j'ai une gueule de bois...
Tu te fous de moi, non ?
Tu me rends ton badge, ton flingue, et tu dégages.
Bonjour patron,
désolé, j'suis en retard,
j'ai une xylostomiase.
Oh merde,
oh mon pauvre vieux, ça c'est la tuile ça...
Allez prends quelques jours pour soigner
cette saloperie, c'est moi qui te les offres.
*YOU WIN*
Autre terme plus récent encore pour
désigner la gueule de bois, la
Veisalgie. Alors ça vient du norvégien "kveis"
*tentatives de pronciation*
Bon, ça veut dire malaise
ou inconfort suivant la débauche, avec
en plus la racine Grecque Algia (algi) qui veut dire douleur
Bon, mais derrière les mots y'a la souffrance et à moins de préférer penser que c'est une espèce de châtiment divin
vous avez sûrement
envie de savoir ce qui se passe dans votre corps, un lendemain de cuite.
Et bien, en réalité la torture imposée
par la gueule de bois elle s'explique
principalement par les efforts que fait
votre corps pour éliminer l'alcool
Et elle commence quand son taux dans le sang approche 0.
Pourquoi ? Bah il faut aller chercher la réponse du côté de notre foie.
C'est lui qui est chargé d'éliminer 90
% de l'alcool qu'on s'envoie
et il lui faut environ
1h30 pour éliminer un verre.
Mais c'est après, que le plus dur commence.
Une fois dégradé par le foie l'alcool se transforme en acétaldéhyde,
une substance toxique et cancérigène, en plus.
Elle s'accumule dans l'organisme
et elle est responsable de symptômes comme
les maux de tête, les nausées, les
vomissements ou les tremblements.
Et c'est encore au foie que revient la
tâche d'éliminer cet acétaldéhyde,
mais le problème c'est que ça
se fait très lentement,
parce qu'il n'est équipé que pour en traiter une toute petite quantité.
Quand on boit de l'alcool notre organisme demande
aussi un petit effort à nos reins,
Pour chasser l'intrus, ils éliminent plus d'eau que d'habitude
C'est pour ça qu'on fait plus pipi
c'est ce qui explique ce qui pourrait
passer pour un paradoxe plus on boit
plus on est déshydratés , oui parce qu'on urine plus de liquide qu'on en boit en réalité
et du coup le corps va puiser dans ses reserves d'eau personnelles, notamment dans celle du cerveau
et ça, ça pique
je suis pas sûr que ce soit très
clair, je vais vous montrer plutôt
ça c'est votre cerveau en temps normal
et ça, c'est votre cerveau un lendemain de cuite.
Bon, je caricature un peu, mais vous avez l'idée
cette déshydratation est notamment
responsable des maux de tête mais aussi
des crampes musculaires. L'alcool lui-même
et la déshydratation font aussi du mal
à vos sinus, ce qui donne cette
espèce de douleur du visage vraiment caractéristique.
vous savez de quoi je parle
Autre responsable du malaise, des
substances chimiques qu'on appelle les
congénères et qui viennent de la
fermentation de l'alcool, ou qui sont
ajoutés dedans artificiellement.
Il y en a plus dans les alcools bruns que dans
les alcools blancs et aussi dans les
alcools de mauvaise qualité
pour finir sachez que si l'alcool aide à
a s'endormir, il détériore
sérieusement la qualité du sommeil en perturbant ses cycles et en aggravant
les troubles du sommeil notamment ceux
qui sont liés à la respiration
comme les apnées ou les ronflements
et là aussi vous savez quoi je parle
Il réduit aussi ce qu'on appelle le
sommeil paradoxal pendant lequel le
cerveau remet un petit peu d'ordre dans ses
affaires
c'est ce qui explique la fatigue
extrême et la confusion les jours de gueule de bois
alors vous aller me demander "mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire"
*Mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire?*
Ok, donc tu vas faire cette blague à
chaque fois en fait
L'idéal c'est de boire moins, mais si vous étiez capable de résister à l'appel
de l'alcool on serait pas là entrain de parler de ça
donc je vais quand même vous donner
deux ou trois trucs
avant la soirée, d'abord, manger tout
simplement. Avant d'aller faire la fête
faites vous un bon repas bien consistant riche en protéines et en sucres lents
Genre une bonne plâtrée de pâtes
Ah oui, un petit conseil quand même au moment de choisir votre menu
souvenez-vous qu'il a une petite chance
pour que ce que vous allez manger sans
ça revienne vous faire un petit coucou pendant la
soirée
pendant la soirée
buvez, mais pas que l'alcool. Quatre
verres d'alcool ça vous fait perdre
1 litre d'eau donc entre chaque verre,
prenez une boisson non alcoolisée
De préférence de l'eau ou un jus de fruit
Parce que le fructose ça aide à éliminer l'alcool, mais aussi l'acétaldéhyde
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure.
Choisissez ce que vous buvez plutôt
de la bière ou des alcools blancs et de
préférence de bonne qualité.
Ah oui et le coup des mélanges qui rendent malade c'est
une légende urbaine
le lendemain
Bon, on y est, vous avez fait n'importe quoi, vous avez la gueule de bois
Mais vous pouvez encore limiter la casse. Avant de commencer, très important:
prenez une pastille à la menthe
Vous allez être une loque toute la journée, vous allez avoir besoin d'aide
et personne n'acceptera de vous approcher, tant que vous aurez
cette haleine de bidet bouché. Ensuite, là encore, buvez de l'eau pour lutter contre la déshydratation
par petits verres si vous êtes
moyennement sereins digéstivement parlant
mais régulièrement. Vous pouvez aussi boire des tisanes, des bouillons salés
ou un peu de jus de tomate par
contre limitez le thé ou le café parce que
ça aggrave la déshydratation et ça
accélère le rythme cardiaque
il est déjà mis à rude épreuve
par votre état.
Un peu de sucré aussi pour lutter contre l'hypoglycémie
le soda c'est pas mal et
notamment le Sprite apparemment selon une étude chinoise
Si vous retirez les bulles, c'est encore mieux
Oui, parce que bon..
Oui, par contre le coup de soigner le
mal par le mal, oubliez tout de suite
reboire verre d'alcool ça va peut-être vous
soulager deux minutes mais ça va
surtout redonner du travail à votre
foie
Et il a vraiment autre chose à faire
Ah oui, j'ai vraiment autre chose à faire
manger aussi, mais pas n'importe quoi
désolé mais le coup du kebab ou du gros burger bien gras
qui éponge tout, bah c'est mytho aussi
Bah oui, parce que devinez qui est chargé d'éliminer les graisses?
Eh ouais, c'est moi
et j'ai vraiment autre chose à faire
Bon allez laissez le bosser tranquille et mangez plutôt des trucs qui se digèrent facilement
comme du blanc de poulet, du pain, des légumes, des yaourts,
des fruits genres des bananes
Ah! évitez tout ce qui est acide. Un oeuf poché c'est bien aussi
Et si vous aimez le miel vous privez pas et,
petit conseil, avant de manger prenez
un citrate de bétaïne
ça évitera des drames
alors comme tout ça ça suffit rarement
vous allez sûrement être tentés de
prendre des médicaments
mais le problème c'est que l'aspirine
et l'ibuprofène
c'est mauvais pour l'estomac
et le paracétamol comme le doliprane
par exemple allié à l'alcool c'est
toxique pour le foie prenez plutôt une
bonne douche bien chaude
et des que vous en sentez capable allez faire un
petit tour à pied pour vous réveiller
Bon alors pas la peine de courir un semi-marathon non plus, vous allez pas éliminer plus vite.
Par contre vous risquez de vous choper des jolies crampes
Alors on est d'accord, le meilleur moyen d'éviter la gueule de bois
ça reste de boire peu..
mais c'est surtout le meilleur moyen
d'éviter tout le reste
parce que l'alcool
c'est responsables de 40 à 50 milles
morts chaque année en France
et c'est la deuxième cause de mortalité évitable
après le tabac. Ok j'ai chié l'ambiance
mais pensez-y quand même. Pour le reste
et parce qu'on sait tous que vous
allez quand même continuer à faire la
fête
Bah maintenant vous savez quoi faire
vous avez des questions à me poser sur ce sujet
ou un autre qui concerne le corps humain, laissez-moi un commentaire
et on en reparle en attendant abonnez-vous pour ne rien rater, et à bientôt
Où ça? Bah DTC